.
THEY DON'T HAVE A PERMANENT ONE.
>> THEY HAD A HEARING.
WE'LL SEE IF IT BECOMES
PERMANENT.
WE'LL GET TO THAT LATER IN THE
SHOW.
ALSO, WE'RE SEEING TENSION
ESCALATE AFTER THE PENTAGON SAID
THAT A RUSSIAN FIGHTER JET
CLIPPED A U.S. SPY DRONE AND
FORCED THE U.S. TO DOWN IT.
THE DANGEROUS ENCOUNTER HAPPENED
OVER THE BLACK SEA.
A RUSSIAN JET DUMPED FUEL ON THE
DRONE SEVERAL TIMES THEN CLIPPED
THE PROPELLER WHICH FORCED THE
U.S. TO DOWN IT INTO THE WATER
NEARBY.
THEY'RE STILL WORKING TO RECOVER
IT THIS MORNING, ACTUALLY.
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
SPOKESMAN SAID THE CONFRONTATION
IS RECKLESS.
>> WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS WAR
ESCALATE BEYOND WHAT IT ALREADY
HAS DONE TO THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
SO THIS IS CLEARLY -- THIS WAS
INAPPROPRIATE, UNSAFE,
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT BY THE
RUSSIAN PILOTS.
>> AFTER THAT HAPPENED, THE U.S.
SUMMONED RUSSIA'S AMBASSADOR TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM HERE.
HE WAS GOING IN AND WAS THERE
FOR 30 MINUTES.
HE CLAIMED THERE WAS NO
COLLISION.
THE U.S. HAS BEEN WARNED NOT TO
ENTER U.S. AIRSPACE THAT'S SWAR
-- AS THIS WAR IS RAGING ON IN
UKRAINE.
>> YOU WILL SEE WHAT WILL BE THE
ACTION OF THE UNITED STATES IF
YOU SEE SUCH RUSSIAN DRONES VERY
CLOSE, FOR EXAMPLE, TO SAN
FRANCISCO OR NEW YORK.
WHAT WILL THE UNITED STATES DO?
FOR ME, IT'S CLEAR.
>> THOSE ARE COMMENTS HE MADE
AFTER LEAVING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT YESTERDAY.
AGAIN, THAT IS THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S.
ALL THIS COMES AS PRESIDENT
PUTIN IS ABOUT TO MAKE A PUBLIC
APPEARANCE ANY MOMENT NOW.
WE'RE WAITING TO SEE IF HE
WEIGHS IN ON THE DRONE INCIDENT.
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY REPORTER
NATASHA BERTRAND IS COVERING
THIS DEVELOPING STORY.
THE U.S. SAYS THE INTERCEPTIONS
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
THE WAY THIS HAPPENED, THIS
CONTACT BETWEEN THE RUSSIA AND
THE U.S. MILITARIES, FIRST WE'VE
SEEN OF SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
THIS GRAVE.
WHAT ELSE DO WE KNOW?
>> OF COURSE IT COMES AT A VERY
SENSITIVE TIME BETWEEN THE U.S.
AND RUSSIA.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY'RE BOTH
OPERATING IN THE REGION AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR ESCALATION AND
MISCALCULATION IS VERY HIGH.
SO WHAT WE'RE LEARNING IS THAT
THE RUSSIAN FIGHTER JETS KIND OF
TRACKED THIS DRONE FOR ABOUT 30
TO 40 MINUTES OVER THE BLACK
SEA, IN INTERNATIONAL WATERS,
BEFORE COMING CLOSE TO THE DRONE
AND ACTUALLY DUMPING FUEL ON IT.
AND THEN GOING BEHIND THE DRONE
AND MAKING CONTACT WITH THE
PROPELLER CAUSING THE DRONE TO
ESSENTIALLY BECOME INOPERABLE,
FORCING THE U.S. MILITARY TO
THEN TAKE IT DOWN OVER
INTERNATIONAL WATERS.
THE U.S. IS SAYING THE PILOTS
LACKED CONFIDENCE AND THEY WERE
RECKLESS.
WAS THIS AN UNSAFE MANEUVER BY
THE PILOT ITSELF OR SOMETHING
THAT CAME FROM THE KREMLIN?
THE PENTAGON IS NOT SAYING AT
THIS MOMENT.
THEY'RE WARNING THE RUSSIANS
THAT THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR CAN
CAUSE AN ESCALATION THAT COULD
DRAW THE TWO COUNTRIES INTO A
CONFLICT.
THE PENTAGON SAYING THAT THERE
WAS NO CONFRONTATION -- THERE
WAS NO COMMUNICATION WHILE THIS
CONFRONTATION.
THAT MAKES US WONDER IF THE
LINES OF COMMUNICATION ARE
OPENING OPERATING PROPERLY.
>> THE U.S. IS WORKING TO
RECOVER THIS.
WHAT IS THE CONCERN THAT
OFFICIALS HAVE IF RUSSIA GETS
THERE FIRST?
>> IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THE U.S.
WILL BE ABLE TO RECOVER THIS.
WE'RE TOLD THAT THERE ARE NO
NAVAL ASSETS IN THE BLACK SEA AT
THIS MOMENT THAT ARE WORKING TO
RECOVER IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS SAID THAT
THEY HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO PROTECT
THEIR EQUITIES.
THEY WOULD NOT GO ANY FURTHER
THAN THAT.
BUT IMPLYING, ESSENTIALLY,
THEY'RE TAKING STEPS TO PREVENT
THE DRONE FROM FALLING INTO
RUSSIAN HANDS.
THE PENTAGON PRESS SECRETARY WAS
ASKED ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY,
WHETHER THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN
THEMSELVES TRYING TO GET AHOLD
OF THE DRONE WHICH AGAIN FELL
INTO THE BLACK SEA.
THEY WOULD NOT GO THERE.
WHAT WE'RE TOLD IS THAT THEY ARE
TAKING ALL POSSIBLE STEPS TO
PREVENT SENSITIVE TECH
KNOWLEDGE, OF COURSE, THIS DRONE
FROM FALLING INTO RUSSIAN HANDS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
>> OBVIOUSLY, SOMETHING THE
WHITE HOUSE IS FOLLOWING.
I WANT TO GET NOW TO CNN'S
PRESILLA ALVAREZ FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS BRIEFED
ON THIS YESTERDAY BY NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER JAKE SULLIVAN.
THE THROUGH LINE AS YOU HEARD
FROM NATASHA IS THAT THE CONTACT
BY THE RUSSIAN PILOTS WAS,
QUOTE, INAPPROPRIATE, UNSAFE,
AND UNPROFESSIONAL.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AS THEY'VE
ALSO STRESSED THAT INTERCEPTS IN
THIS REGION ARE COMMON.
WHAT WAS DIFFERENT AND UNIQUE
ABOUT THIS INCIDENT WAS JUST HOW
UNSAFE IT IS.
NOW THE WHITE HOUSE HAS ALSO
DISMISSED RUSSIA'S DENIAL OF THE
INCIDENT AND SAID THAT THEY'RE
TAKING STEPS, AGAIN, AS YOU
HEARD THERE, TO PROTECT THEIR
PRIVATE EQUITIES.
BUT NOT SHARING MUCH MORE THAN
THAT.
NOW, OF COURSE, THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN IN TOUCH
WITH ALLIES GOING SO FAR AS TO
ALSO SUMMON THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S. TO RELAY
THE CONCERNS.
BOTTOM LINE IS REALLY THAT THE
U.S. WILL NOT STOP OPERATING IN
THIS REGION.
DON?
>> IS THE WHITE HOUSE HESITANT
TO TAKE FURTHER ACTION AGAINST
RUSSIA HERE?
>> OF COURSE, THIS COMES AT A
CRITICAL TIME.
THERE IS ALWAYS RISK OF A
DANGEROUS ESCALATION.
BUT THEY HAVE STRESSED THEY HAVE
THOSE LINES OF COMMUNICATION,
THE DIPLOMATIC LINES WITH
RUSSIA.
WE SAW EVIDENCE OF THAT
YESTERDAY AGAIN WITH THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S.
AND THAT IS WHERE THEY ARE RIGHT
NOW AT RISK, OF COURSE, OF ANY
ESCALATION.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
AVOID.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
>> LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT WHAT
HAS DEVELOPED HERE.
OUR CNN MILITARY ANALYST IS
HERE.
CEDRIC, GOOD MORNING.
EXPLAIN TO US WHAT THE
CAPABILITIES ARE OF WHAT IS
KNOWN AS AN MQ 9 REAPER DRONE.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT JOHN
KIRBY IS SAYING WHEN HE SAYS
THEY'RE WORKING TO, QUOTE,
PROTECT THE EQUITIES OF IT?
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
POPPY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
THE WHOLE BUSINESS HERE IS, OF
COURSE, ABOUT SENSITIVE
INTELLIGENCE.
THE BASIC CAPABILITIES OF THE
REAPER, IT FLIES AT 50,000 FEET.
ALMOST AS HIGH AS THAT BALLOON
THAT WE SHOT DOWN OFF THE COAST
OF SOUTH CAROLINA.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT'S AN
INTELLIGENCE COLLECTION
PLATFORM.
IT CAN BE AN ARMED PLATFORM.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, I'M
CERTAIN IT WAS INTELLIGENCE
COLLECTION PLATFORM.
SUPPORTS STRIKE MISSIONS BUT
MAINLY DONE FOR SURVEILLANCE.
ONE BIG THING ABOUT THIS IS IT
HAS A RANGE OF ABOUT 1150 MILES.
IT CAN STAY UP FOR ABOUT 24
HOURS.
IT HAS A BIG WING SPAN OF 66
FEET.
IT'S WIDER THAN A LOT OF
AIRCRAFT.
IT CAN DO A LOT OF COLLECTION
INTELLIGENCE SOURCES, SIGNALS
AND IMAGERY INTELLIGENCE.
P THAT'S WHY IT'S A BIG DEAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT RUSSIANS DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY HOW GOOD IT IS AT
COLLECTING THIS KIND OF
INTELLIGENCE.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY INSIGHT INTO
HOW THE U.S. COULD REMOTELY IF
THEY DON'T GET THEIR HANDS ON IT
FIRST, HOW CAN THEY REMOTELY
PROTECT THAT INTELLIGENCE?
>> THEY CAN ZEROIZE THE
EQUIPMENT.
THEY CAN TAKE THE VIDEOS NEWLY
AND VOID.
ANYBODY WHO LOOKS AT THAT THEN
WON'T BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT HAS
BEEN TRANSMITTED.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
HAPPENED.
IT'S THE DETAILS FROM JOHN KIRBY
THAT ARE FASCINATING.
BASICALLY, THE RUSSIAN FIGHTER
JETS WERE FLYING IN FRONT OF THE
DRONE AND DUMPING FUEL ON IT
BEFORE THIS EVEN HAPPENED.
YOU THINK IT WAS A MISTAKE THEY
CLIPPED THE WING, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I DO THINK THAT, KAITLAN.
THE REASON I THINK IT WAS A
MISTAKE IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
WAY IN WHICH THESE DRONES
OPERATE AND THE WAY IN WHICH THE
RUSSIANS FLY THEIR AIRCRAFT,
THEY COME REALLY CLOSE TO THIS.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF THE DRONE
AS IT'S GETTING READY TO TAKE
OFF H WHAT THE RUSSIANS DID IS
THEY WENT TO THIS AREA RIGHT
HERE, DUMPED FUEL ON THIS PART
AND THEN THEY MOVED BACK AS THE
CRAFT WAS FLYING AND THEY HIT
THE PROPELLER RIGHT THERE.
THAT WAS THE KEY THING.
WHEN IT -- WHEN THEY DID THAT,
THAT MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE
DRONE TO FLY.
THE AIR FORCE WHICH WAS
OPERATING THIS REMOTELY HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO BASICALLY LET IT
SINK INTO THE OCEAN INTO THE
BLACK SEA.
THEY MADE IT THAT WAY BECAUSE
THEY NEEDED TO CLEAR IT FROM THE
SKY SO IT WASN'T A RISK TO OTHER
AVIATION ASSETS.
>> WHAT STANDS OUT TO ME IS JUST
LOOKING AT THE DRONE.
IT'S ENORMOUS DRONE.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T THINK OF
THEM --
>> IT'S NOT LIKE A HOUSEHOLD
DRONE.
>> IT IS.
TAKE A LOOK RIGHT HERE, DON.
WHAT YOU CAN SEE, 36 FEET IN
LENGTH, THE WING SPAN IS 66
FEET.
COMPARE THAT TO THE RUSSIAN
FIGHTER WHICH IS LONGER.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING THERE IS
REALLY A RELATIVE COMPARISON.
THIS IS A SMALLER AIRCRAFT.
IT IS A HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
AIRCRAFT.
THESE GUYS CAN FLY FASTER THAN
THE REAPER CAN.
>> IS THAT A TYPICAL SIZE?
>> YEAH.
THAT'S THE AVERAGE SIZE OF A
REAPER RIGHT HERE AND OF THE